Primero, si nos fijamos en el nivel de desigualdad de la riqueza,
esta es la parte de la riqueza total
que va al 10 % de los ricos,
así que pueden ver el mismo tipo de reversión
entre EE.UU. y Europa que teníamos antes
de la desigualdad de ingresos.
La concentración de la riqueza fue mayor
en Europa que en EE.UU. hace un siglo,
y ahora es lo contrario.
Pero también pueden ver dos cosas:
En primer lugar, el nivel general de desigualdad de la riqueza
es siempre mayor que la desigualdad de ingresos.
Recuerden, por la desigualdad de ingresos,
la proporción que va al 10 %
fue entre el 30 % y el 50 % de los ingresos totales,
mientras que para la riqueza, la participación es siempre
entre el 60 % y el 90 %.
Bien, este es el primer hecho,
y es muy importante para lo que sigue.
La concentración de la riqueza es siempre
mucho más alta que la del ingreso.
El hecho número dos es que el aumento
en desigualdad de la riqueza en las últimas décadas
aún no es suficiente para igualar el de 1910.
La gran diferencia en la actualidad,
la desigualdad de la riqueza sigue siendo muy grande,
con el 60 %, 70 % de la riqueza total para el 10 % superior,
pero la buena noticia es que en realidad es
mejor que hace un siglo,
en el que en Europa fue de 90 % para el 10 % superior.
Hoy lo que tenemos
es lo que yo llamo el medio 40 %,
los que no están en el 10 % superior
y que no se encuentran en el 50 % inferior,
y que pueden ver como la clase media rica
que es propietaria del 20 % al 30 %
de la riqueza total, riqueza nacional,
y que eran pobres, hace un siglo,
cuando no había básicamente, clase media rica.
Este es un cambio importante,
y es interesante ver que la desigualdad de la riqueza
no se ha recuperado a niveles pre I Guerra Mundial,
aunque la cantidad total de la riqueza sí se ha recuperado.
¿Bien? Este es el valor total
de la riqueza en relación con los ingresos,
y se puede ver que, en particular en Europa,
estamos casi de vuelta a los niveles anteriores a la I Guerra Mundial.
Así que en realidad hay dos
diferentes partes de la historia aquí.
Una tiene que ver con
la cantidad total de la riqueza que acumulamos,
y no hay nada malo per se, claro,
en acumular una gran riqueza,
y en particular si está más dispersa
y menos concentrada.
En lo que realmente queremos centrarnos es
en la evolución de largo plazo de la desigualdad de la riqueza
y lo que pasará en el futuro.
¿Cómo podemos explicar el hecho de que
hasta la I Guerra Mundial, la desigualdad de la riqueza era tan alta
y, en todo caso, se elevaba a niveles aún más altos,
y qué podemos pensar hacia el futuro?
Déjenme hacer algunas explicaciones
y especulaciones sobre el futuro.
Permítanme decir que
quizá el mejor modelo para explicar
por qué la riqueza está mucho
más concentrada que el ingreso
es un modelo dinámico, dinástico,
en el que los individuos tienen un largo horizonte
y acumulan riqueza por todo tipo de razones.
Si la gente acumulara riqueza
solo por razones de ciclo de vida,
saben, para ser capaces de consumir
cuando sean viejos,
entonces el nivel de desigualdad de la riqueza
debería estar más o menos en línea
con el de desigualdad en los ingresos.
Pero será muy difícil explicar
por qué hay tanta mayor desigualdad de la riqueza
que desigualdad de ingresos
con un modelo de ciclo de vida,
por lo que se necesita una historia
en a las personas también les preocupe
la acumulación de riqueza por otras razones.
Por lo general, quieren transmitir
su riqueza a la siguiente generación, a sus hijos,
o, a veces quieren acumular riquezas
por el prestigio, el poder que va con la riqueza.
Debe haber otras razones
para la acumulación de riqueza que el solo ciclo de vida
para explicar lo que vemos en los datos.
Ahora, en una gran clase de modelos dinámicos
la acumulación de riqueza
con tal motivo dinástico para la acumulación de riqueza,
tendrá toda clase de azar,
choques multiplicativos.
Así, por ejemplo, algunas familias
tienen un gran número de niños,
por lo que la riqueza se dividirá.
Algunas familias tienen menos hijos.
También tienen choques a las tasas de interés.
Algunas hacen enormes ganancias de capital.
Algunas hicieron malas inversiones.
Así que siempre tendrán cierta movilidad
en el proceso de la riqueza.
Algunas personas se moverán hacia arriba o hacia abajo.
El punto importante es que,
en cualquier modelo,
para una variación dada de tales choques,
el nivel de equilibrio de la desigualdad de la riqueza
será una función rápidamente creciente de r menos g.
Y de forma intuitiva, la razón por la que la diferencia
entre la tasa de interés de la riqueza
y la de crecimiento es importante,
es que las desigualdades iniciales de riqueza
se amplifican a un ritmo más rápido
con una más grande r menos g.
Tomen un ejemplo sencillo:
con r igual a 5 % y g igual a 1 %,
los ricos solo tienen que reinvertir
1/5 parte de sus ingresos de capital para asegurar
que su riqueza aumenta tan rápido
como el tamaño de la economía.
Esto hace que sea más fácil
construir y perpetuar grandes fortunas
porque se pueden consumir 4/5 partes,
asumiendo cero impuestos,
y se puede reinvertir 1/5 parte.
Por supuesto, algunas familias consumirán más que eso,
algunas menos, por lo que habrá
cierta movilidad en la distribución,
pero, en promedio, solo tienen que reinvertir 1/5
lo que permite las altas desigualdades en riqueza se mantengan.
Ahora, no se deben sorprender
por la afirmación de que r puede ser más grande que g para siempre,
porque, de hecho, es lo que pasó
durante la mayor parte de la historia.
Y es algo muy obvio para todos
por una sencilla razón, que el crecimiento
estuvo cerca del 0 %
durante casi toda la historia.
El crecimiento fue tal vez 0,1 %, 0,2 %, 0,3 %,
con un muy lento crecimiento de la población
y del producto per cápita,
mientras que la tasa de interés del capital
por supuesto no era 0 %.
Era, para los activos de la tierra, que era
la forma tradicional
de activos en las sociedades preindustriales,
era típicamente 5 %.
Cualquier lector de Jane Austen sabría eso.
Si quieres un ingreso anual de 1000 libras,
debes tener un capital
de 20 000 libras ya que
el 5 % de 20 000 es 1000.
Y en cierto modo, esta era
la base misma de la sociedad,
porque que r fuera más grande que g
fue lo que permitió a los dueños de la riqueza y los activos
vivir de sus ingresos de capital
y hacer otra cosa en la vida
no solo cuidar de su propia supervivencia.
Ahora, una conclusión importante
de mi investigación histórica es que
el crecimiento industrial moderno no cambió
este hecho básico tanto como se podría haber esperado.
Claro, la tasa de crecimiento
después de la Revolución Industrial
rosa, típicamente, de 0 % a 1 % a 2 %,
pero al mismo tiempo, la tasa de interés
del capital también aumentó,
por lo que la brecha entre las dos
realmente no cambia.
Así que durante el siglo XX,
tenemos una combinación única de acontecimientos.
Primero, una muy baja tasa de interés
debido a los choques por las guerras de 1914 y 1945,
la destrucción de la riqueza, la inflación,
la quiebra durante la Gran Depresión,
y todo esto redujo
la tasa de rentabilidad privada de la riqueza
a niveles inusualmente bajos
entre 1914 y 1945.
Y luego, en el período de posguerra,
se tiene una inusualmente alta tasa de crecimiento,
debido en parte a la reconstrucción.
Ya saben, en Alemania, Francia, Japón,
había crecimientos del 5 %
entre 1950 y 1980
debido en gran parte a la reconstrucción,
y también debido al gran crecimiento demográfico,
el efecto de la generación 'baby boom'.
Al parecer, eso no va a durar por mucho tiempo,
o al menos el crecimiento de la población
se supone que disminuirá en el futuro,
y las mejores proyecciones que tenemos es que
el crecimiento a largo plazo va a estar más cerca
del 1 % al 2 %
que del 4 % a 5 %.
Así que si vemos esto,
son las mejores estimaciones que tenemos
de crecimiento del PBI mundial
y la tasa de interés del capital,
tasas promedio de interés sobre el capital,
y pueden ver que durante la mayor parte
de la historia de la humanidad,
la tasa de crecimiento era muy pequeña,
mucho más baja que la tasa de interés,
y luego durante el siglo XX,
es realmente el crecimiento de la población,
muy alto en el período de posguerra,
y el proceso de reconstrucción,
los que trajeron crecimiento
y una menor brecha con la tasa de interés.
Aquí, he usado las proyecciones de población de Naciones Unidas,
así que por supuesto no son seguras.
Podría ser que empezáramos
a tener un montón de niños en el futuro,
y las tasas de crecimiento vayan a ser mayores,
pero por ahora,
estas son las mejores proyecciones que tenemos,
y son que el crecimiento mundial
declinará y la brecha entre
la tasa de rentabilidad, subirá.
Ahora, el otro hecho insólito
durante el siglo XX
fue, como he dicho,
la destrucción, la tributación del capital,
así que esta es la tasa antes de impuestos de utilidades.
Esta es la tasa después de impuestos,
y después de la destrucción,
y esto es lo que trajo
la tasa media de rentabilidad
después de impuestos, y destrucción,
bajo la tasa de crecimiento por un largo período.
Pero sin la destrucción,
sin impuestos, esto no habría sucedido.
Así que permítanme decir que el equilibrio entre
rendimientos del capital y crecimiento
depende de muchos factores diferentes
que son muy difíciles de predecir:
la tecnología y el desarrollo
de técnicas intensivas en capital.
Ahora mismo, los sectores más intensivos en capital
en la economía son el sector inmobiliario, la vivienda,
el sector energético, pero podría ser que en el futuro
tengamos muchos más robots en una serie de sectores
y que esto sería una porción mayor
del total de capital que el actual.
Bueno, estamos muy lejos de esto,
y por ahora, lo qué está pasando
en los sectores inmobiliario y de energía,
es mucho más importante para el capital total
y la cuota de capital.
La otra cuestión importante
es que hay efectos de escala en la gestión de carteras,
junto con la complejidad financiera,
la desregulación financiera,
que hacen que sea más fácil conseguir mayores tasas de interés
para una cartera grande,
y esto parece ser particularmente fuerte
para multimillonarios, grandes fondos de capital.
Solo para dar un ejemplo,
esto viene de la clasificación de multimillonarios de Forbes
durante el período 1987-2013,
y pueden ver que los más ricos
han estado creciendo al 6 % o 7 % al año
en términos reales por encima de la inflación,
mientras que el ingreso promedio en el mundo,
el promedio de riqueza mundial,
han aumentado en solo un 2 % por año.
Y encuentran lo mismo
para las grandes fundaciones universitarias,
cuanto mayor el fondo inicial
mayor la tasa de interés.
Ahora, ¿qué se podría hacer?
La primera cosa es que creo que necesitamos
más transparencia financiera.
Sabemos muy poco sobre la dinámica de la riqueza mundial,
por lo que necesitamos la transmisión internacional
de la información bancaria.
Necesitamos un registro global de los activos financieros,
una mayor coordinación en materia de impuestos a la riqueza,
e incluso un impuesto sobre el patrimonio, con una pequeña tasa
sería una manera de generar información
para que entonces podamos adaptar nuestras políticas
a lo que observemos.
Y hasta cierto punto, la lucha
contra los paraísos fiscales
y la transmisión automática de la información
nos está empujando en esta dirección.
Hay otras formas de redistribución de la riqueza,
que pueden ser tentadoras.
Inflación:
es mucho más fácil imprimir dinero
que hacer una legislación impositiva, así que es muy tentador,
pero a veces no se sabe lo que se hace con el dinero.
Este es un problema.
La expropiación es muy tentadora.
Justo cuando sientes que algunas personas son demasiado ricas,
simplemente las expropias.
Pero no es muy eficiente
organizar una regulación de la dinámica de la riqueza.
La guerra es una manera aún mucho menos eficiente,
así que prefiero los impuestos progresivos,
pero, por supuesto, la historia (Risas)
la historia inventará sus propias mejores maneras,
y es probable que involucren
una combinación de todo esto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Thomas Piketty. Gracias.
Thomas, quiero hacerte 2 o 3 preguntas,
porque es impresionante cómo dominas tus datos, por supuesto,
pero básicamente sugieres que
la creciente concentración de la riqueza es una especie
de tendencia natural del capitalismo
y que, si lo dejamos a su suerte,
puede poner en peligro el propio sistema,
por lo que estás sugiriendo que hay que actuar
para implementar políticas que redistribuyen la riqueza,
incluyendo las que acabamos de ver:
impuestos progresivos, etc.
En el contexto político actual,
¿qué tan realistas son?
¿Qué tan probable crees que es
que se lleven a cabo?
Thomas Piketty: Bueno, creo que
si miramos atrás en el tiempo,
la historia de la renta, el patrimonio y los impuestos
está llena de sorpresas.
No me impresionan mucho
los que saben de antemano
lo que va o no va a pasar.
Creo que hace un siglo,
mucha gente habría dicho
que los impuestos progresivos a la renta nunca se darían
y luego sucedió.
Y hace cinco años,
mucha gente habría dicho que el secreto bancario
estaría con nosotros para siempre en Suiza,
que Suiza era demasiado poderosa
para el resto del mundo,
y de repente se dieron unas sanciones de EE.UU.
contra los bancos suizos para que se diera un gran cambio,
y ahora nos estamos moviendo hacia
mayor transparencia financiera.
Así que creo que no es tan difícil
coordinar mejor las políticas.
Vamos a tener un tratado
con la mitad del PBI mundial en la mesa,
con EE.UU. y la Unión Europea,
y si la mitad del PBI mundial no es suficiente
para avanzar en la transparencia financiera
y el impuesto mínimo para las ganancias corporativas multinacionales,
¿qué se necesita?
Así que creo que no se trata de dificultades técnicas.
Creo que podemos hacer progresos
si tenemos un enfoque más pragmático a estas preguntas
y tenemos las sanciones adecuadas
para quienes se benefician de la opacidad financiera.
BG: Uno de los argumentos
en contra de tu punto de vista
es que la desigualdad económica
no es solo una característica del capitalismo, sino que es uno de sus motores.
Así que si tomamos medidas para reducir la desigualdad,
al mismo tiempo tendremos un menor crecimiento, potencialmente.
¿Qué respondes a eso?
TP: Sí, creo que la desigualdad
no es un problema per se.
Creo que la desigualdad hasta un punto
en realidad puede ser útil para la innovación y el crecimiento.
El problema es que es una cuestión de grado.
Cuando la desigualdad se hace demasiado extrema,
a continuación, se vuelve inútil para el crecimiento
e incluso puede llegar a ser mala
porque tiende a conducir a alta perpetuación
de desigualdad en el tiempo
y baja movilidad.
Y por ejemplo, el tipo de concentraciones de riqueza
que teníamos en el siglo XIX
y más o menos hasta la I Guerra Mundial
en todos los países europeos
no era, creo, nada útil para el crecimiento.
Fue destruida por una combinación
de eventos trágicos y cambios de política,
y esto no impidió que el crecimiento se diera.
Y también, la desigualdad extrema puede ser mala
para nuestras instituciones democráticas
si crea un acceso muy desigual a la voz política,
y la influencia del dinero privado
en la política estadounidense, creo,
es un motivo de preocupación en este momento.
Así que no queremos volver a esta clase de extremo,
de desigualdad pre I Guerra Mundial.
Tener una cuota decente de la riqueza nacional
para la clase media no es mala para el crecimiento.
En realidad, es útil
tanto por razones de equidad como de eficiencia.
BG: Dije al principio
que tu libro ha sido criticado.
Algunos de datos han sido criticados.
Parte de tu elección de conjuntos de datos ha sido criticada.
Se te ha acusado elegir datos intencionadamente
para soportar tu caso. ¿Qué respondes a eso?
TP: Bueno, respondo que estoy muy feliz
de que este libro haya estimulado el debate.
Es parte de su propósito.
Mira, la razón por la que pongo todos los datos en línea
con todo el cálculo detallado
es para que podamos tener un diálogo abierto y transparente,
debatir sobre esto.
He respondido punto por punto
a cada preocupación.
Permítanme decir que si fuera a reescribir el libro hoy,
hubiera realmente concluido
que el aumento de la desigualdad de la riqueza,
particularmente en EE.UU.,
en realidad ha sido más alta que lo que reporto en mi libro.
Hay un estudio reciente realizado por Saez y Zucman
que muestra, con nuevos datos
que no tenía en el momento del libro,
que la concentración de la riqueza en EE.UU. ha aumentado
incluso más de lo que reporto.
Y habrá otros datos en el futuro.
Algunos irán en diferentes direcciones.
Mira, nosotros ponemos en línea casi todas las semanas
un nueva serie actualizada en la base de World Top Income
y seguiremos haciéndolo en el futuro,
en particular de los países emergentes,
y doy la bienvenida a todos aquellos que quieran contribuir
a este proceso de recolección de datos.
De hecho, claramente estoy de acuerdo
que no hay suficiente
transparencia sobre la dinámica de la riqueza,
y una buena manera de tener mejores datos
sería contar con un impuesto sobre el patrimonio
con una pequeña tasa, para empezar
por lo que todos podamos estar de acuerdo
sobre esta importante evolución
y adaptar nuestras políticas a lo que observemos.
Los impuestos son fuente de conocimiento,
y eso es lo que más necesitamos en estos momentos.
BG: Thomas Piketty, merci beaucoup.
Gracias. TP: Gracias. (Aplausos)